[Music]
[Applause]
she-hulk first appears in February of
1980 and the savage she-hulk issue
number one and is created by Stan Lee
and John Mishima and issue number one we
see that she hoax actual name is
Jennifer Walters she is the cousin of
Bruce Banner and she is a defense
attorney an element of her personality
and her ego Jennifer Walters that will
remain for her entire publication
history and issue number one we see that
her current client is being framed by a
mobster named Nick Trask we see that
Nick Trask puts a hit out on Jennifer
Walters and the two individuals that he
hired are successful in injuring her as
a result her cousin Bruce Banner has to
give her a blood transfusion later on on
the comic we will see that she
transforms into she-hulk for the very
first time between issues number two and
issues number ten we see that she is an
almost identical clone of Bruce Banner
in the sense that she requires anger to
transform from Jennifer Walters and a
she-hulk however an issues number 11 and
issues number 12 between December and
January of 1980 and 1981 she will be
cured by a blood disease by Michael
Morbius an antihero from the spider-man
comics who first appeared in spider-man
issue number 101 this marks the first
time that we will ever see her transform
from Jennifer Walters into she-hulk at
will without requiring anger over the
course of her publication history we
will see she-hulk placed several major
roles two of the most notable being a
member of the Avengers as well as a
stand-in for the thing at work and the
events leading up to the Marvel Civil
War storyline we will see her maintain
her role as a lawyer albeit for
superhumans in addition to being married
to John Jameson the son of Jay jonah
Jameson again I hope you guys enjoyed
this video
and please keep in mind this is not
designed to be a full discussion on
she-hulk this is simply designed to
refresh you guys or to introduce you
guys to a character on the base level so
that you will understand who she is as
we get into the Civil War storyline
[Music]